let's work at a liquor store in high
school in canyon country
uh and there was a police officer that
would go in there and he was a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and they used to have these tubes of
jerky in the front of the thing
and long like that i put them in my kulo
and walk around
five minutes and then i would put them
back in the tube
but i put them in my ass like like like
a straw between my crack
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez
oh my god omg omg
this is all very exciting gil you know
we're six months in
and amazon you can listen to omg high on
amazon
and we're going to be featured on a
billboard in times square so thank you
amazon and you can listen to
oh my god hi on amazon
nothing but the best i understand this
could be on alexa as well yeah you can
you could say alexa played the podcast
omg high with george lopez on amazon
i'll do it when i get home
alexa play the omg high podcast
should be out listen to that [ __ ]
thank you amazon
[Music]
all right so she's the story previous to
this is
is perfect for where i'm gonna go like
somebody eating by themselves
i said they should look sad okay
because growing up i'm an only child my
my grandparents were disconnected i
spent a lot of time by myself
and i still do like over this week last
weekend i didn't leave the house once
i may have only took a shower once too
nasty but
i'm much like i was you know it's i've
been going to i've been talking to the
same guy
the therapist for 20 years
and i think that i
and i talk to him every every couple of
weeks so mentally i would say mentally
when he and i talk i do
less bad things than i did 20 years ago
than 10 years ago but now
we talk more about things about life and
less things about what i have an issue
with but i know i have an issue with
being reclusive or being in the house
but nothing's keeping me in the house
it's not because you're
either people recognizing it it's been a
long time i'm not i'm used to it if that
but i just did not do not have the
desire
to go out and i remember my therapist
said to me you know what were you doing
when you were 13
thinking he had me like i got this one
what were you doing when you were 13 i
said the same [ __ ] i'm doing now
trying to learn how to play the guitar
watching tv but now there's more to
watch
so you know i don't feel alone
i don't feel lonely but even with the
dogs like i don't connect with the dogs
which is
which is why i started to adopt dogs in
the first place because
the the therapist said hey man you got
to get a dog and you have to make that
dog
like love you like be the master of the
dog so that when you come home he's
happy to see you
and then you're building a relationship
with a dog well i can't even do that
i i i i told you about the stray dog
that came to my house
you can't even so okay so so that dog he
really is i'm the uh
i'm i'm like the alpha this dog comes up
he loves me he cares
and i truly care for the dog you know
not like a
almost like a human i i've seen some
people get carried away
i i'm not that bad but yet i'll take him
to the bed i'll spend money on whatev
whatever he needs
and that that damn dog comes over when i
skinned my knee you notice he comes over
and it's like he knows i'm hurt
and he'll come over and start licking my
knee look look in the wound
you know he gets up every morning i
think they yeah and he comes and he runs
and he jumps in the bed
and he just wants to get next to me and
my wife says
and i don't know why your wife was like
listen yeah
uh the stars got to go
no she's the one that really wanted it
when he got there yeah because she's not
an animal and she took like
she just says i don't know why he does
that i'm the one that cooks i'm the one
that feeds him and i'm the one to take
him out for a walk and think of [ __ ]
and yet he comes to you yeah and she'll
why is that though
do you think you give him like a
different kind of affection or anything
like that
like is there a different i'm the one
that started with him when he first
started coming up need that in my hand
and he was straight too right yeah he
was straight and
we just bonded she'll be out there in
the front yard i'll hear her
milo she'll be yelling for him and then
finally she'll say
gil i'll be in the house gill call milo
one time bam and the dog comes right in
the front door he wants to come back
so he's uh he's all mine and he's the
same way with my son too
same way well from rescuing dogs i know
that
[ __ ] i mean i've seen some dogs that
have been in bad shape
like beautiful dogs there was a dog
that i like a little papi on little
black and white one that was old
name was uh um what was his name
kip kip kipling kipling i guess i got
him
poet's name and yeah and
if i would hold him he would literally
he would share he would [ __ ] he would be
he and he would stiffen up like like
this
like if they handed him to me he'd
stiffen up he would [ __ ]
and you tell the rescue ladies like why
does he do that he goes oh you know some
of these dogs are abused by
men most of most of the abusers of pets
are men and
his recollection of men is that they
beat him up or did whatever to him and
then they tighten up and
and out of fear they should like i
remember the
the the the cr
i don't see them i want to say the right
word the
lisa when lisa was in here from the big
love rescue dog rescue
we did a show together and she's and i
said so what do you do oh you know i
work at big love rescue
or it was hope for paws she goes you
ever seen those videos of dogs
and i said no like sarah mclaughlin's
like a sad story
she goes you know if you got time you
know like go in the middle of the night
or go
on youtube and just check them out so
there's videos of dogs that
are waiting at an abandoned house for
the owners to come back
and the owners have left and
they left the dog there and nobody can
go near the dog
neighbors leave like food and water but
water in a half cut
milk jug and food just throw them on the
ground
and they abandon dogs everywhere they
find dogs under the cars they find dogs
in the garage in the corner
and you call this place and then they
come and rescue a dog
and every single one of those dogs
is it's [ __ ] sadder every story is
sadder than the next
i couldn't watch them you could oh yeah
you can't watch them turn to people so i
start watching them
and i start tearing up in the middle of
the night i'm like man but i end up
you know i wake up once maybe at 1 30 2
30. [ __ ]
7 30 in the morning i'm still watching
them
and then you you look at other dogs
being surrendered if when they know
they're being surrendered and they
they stop and literally like just become
part of the pavement and you [ __ ]
have to go pick them up
and there was this lady that surrendered
these two chihuahuas she takes them to
the
shelter and puts them on the counter and
strips them
like [ __ ] inmates at the county jail
takes their [ __ ] collar off one
collar
second caller pulls the shirt off the
other one pulls the shirt off the other
one
takes the leash off hands him and
[ __ ] leaves with the clothes
with the collars and just leaves the dog
there
i took a dog to the dog pound
and the shelter you know now shelter you
know there's a lot of things we're going
to talk about today though
because i've i've i've lined up five
things that you and i don't know that
everybody else knows
and i took it to animal care i took them
to baldwin park animal control yeah
yeah yeah so and this dog i thought this
was going to be my hero i started
calling him storm
he was a husky uh no it wasn't gonna be
[ __ ]
hot it looked like it looked like a
husky it was uh
not a malamute it was a white dog uh
oh samoan samoyed that's what it was it
was a samoyed
in east l.a nobody anymore
nobody in east l.a owns a samoid no and
this dog's a stray and i'm i'm working
patrol i'm a cop car and i come up and
the dog wants to be by me and i started
sharing my food with him give him some
tacos
and he was eating him i opened the door
the dog jumped in wow that's a big deal
and so i said okay come on let's go boy
so i took him down to the station i
called animal control i did the right
thing
i said here he is pick him up take him
as soon as he's available for adoption
call me i want him
i'll take him i don't want anything to
happen on my dog so took him
and by the way sorry to interrupt you
that is the
appropriate way that you do it you don't
see a lot of people that do it the
appropriate way
you did it the 100 way they tell you
find a dog
it's like when somebody used to find a
wallet some people would return the
wallet
these are the days that we lived in you
would find a wallet with money and
you would return the wallet to the
police department or wherever they said
nobody claims it
is yours or wild okay
to think what we where we were as a
society back then
so i go ahead turn in the dog
two weeks later call me up he's ready
and the place was over on garfield
avenue
and before i go in there i buy me a
great big long
expensive leather training leash nothing
but the best of food
everything this is not gonna be a
champion dog i take him home
the dog my wife was so pissed off
first thing he got a hold of was i had a
down jacket i had feathers all over the
goddamn backyard
then next thing i know i had uh
he bit a hole in my swimming pool line
that goes with my pump
so burnt the motor on the pump wasn't
getting water it wasn't good oh wow
because it has expensive tastes
he got into the trash i had trash all
over the goddamn
i had trash all over my place and then
my wife went to clean up the mess she
turned on the hose and there's all kinds
of [ __ ] holes in the game
god damn wow so she just said okay it's
you
or the dog wow not both of you
one of you's got to go wow so i called
up
a society a rescue for some samoids
right what kind of samoid i think right
yeah m-o-y-e-d i bought i bought one of
those
so i got and they said okay here's the
deal
take it back to animal control i promise
you
we'll pick it back up within three to
four days we'll pick it up
we're not gonna let that dog go we have
a society for them
that's good this dog who wouldn't do
[ __ ] for me now
wow i said come on boy i put the leash
oh by the way he chewed through the
leather leash that i bought him too
yeah damn so i gotta see a puppy no
he was if he would i think they're mad
when they do that right i don't even
know i know i don't know
but i don't know psychology yeah so i
went ahead i opened my door
on my pickup damn dog jumped right on in
there
he's ready to go and he's sitting there
he's a proud dog i take him to animal
control
and when i get there i'm walking him in
i see
and there's a little boy that's walking
out with his mommy and he's saying
he looks at me says how could you you're
bringing that dog here so they could
kill him
and i'm saying no no yes you are i know
what goes on around here
and the boy is crying she said come on
come on johnny let's go
whoa that's like a kid said that yeah
because he knew that he thought i was
taking the dog
to put him put him down and he didn't
and he got picked up within three days
because i called the check on him they
said no no he was picking they got they
got him yeah
the rescue got him and nobody want
nobody wanted him well
the rescue wanted him right but they
said they would take it because
when i took him back all i had to do
tell animal control was
he was a stray that i picked up and you
have it documented
and it didn't work out okay so they take
them back no questions asked
but the society for smudge was there
they said we'll be there within three to
four days
we'll pick him up we'll take care of him
nothing's gonna happen to him will make
sure he has
finds a good family home you know some
you know
first of all they from what i from my
studies
they know some don't knock you know they
would say you can't say
all dogs but some dogs know
that they're in the pound
and or in the sh they know and they know
how bad it is
and when they get out they know how
lucky they are to get out
you know and they behave
like they are appreciative to have a
home they know
so very rarely do you see a dog like
that that was a stray
and i think i'm pretty sure wherever he
lived if you go back
somebody probably cut him loose because
he was just
he was just a travison he needed some
discipline he needed
you know dogs she probably was i don't
know if those are inside dogs i guess
they're
all dogs are inside dogs now but before
yeah i was an outside dog
and and i know i didn't get to spend
enough time with them because i was
working
i was on patrol or indoor dogs it says
i googled it well maybe that's why he
did it because i wouldn't let him inside
the wife wouldn't let him inside there
yeah no of course but yeah but
people there mexican didn't let their
dogs inside the house [ __ ] kidding me
nobody had a dog that was inside yeah
like i grew up every [ __ ] my
grandparents were the same way they had
a bunch of dogs all they lived on farms
it's a little different but all outside
like five dogs i have a good buddy named
ray
if he ever listens to this hill he'll
know who i'm talking about oh ray had a
dog and i said what kind of dog food you
feed on me is this a mexican dog he gets
anything that's left over from here
that's it if he doesn't like it hit it
you know exactly the uh i had a
joke that the menudo on tuesday you'd
flip the bowl over the pot over and it
fell out like jello with meat in it
and the dog would run over there and
just start eating it off the sidewalk
off the the concrete sure and i would go
in there
to give him a tortilla
i'm just trying to kick you down a
corner
and uh he just he ate all of it like a
jello with meat in it [ __ ] harmony
and tripe
in the beginning when my dog this this
last one that we had he lives with us
now
i weighed him on weenies he loved
weenies
once we okay he's ours no more weenies
now we get them dog food
dog wouldn't eat the dog food yeah i had
to ask the vet hey you want me to give
them these pills
how do i give them to them because this
guy's just putting his food i said he
doesn't eat dog food
i tried wet i tried canned i tried dried
tried every
he wouldn't eat it all he ate was
weenies when he was with me
and they said get your wife boil some
chicken no seasoning
so she boils chicken she gets uh
veggies you know the frozen corn and
[Music]
yeah not corn but carrots and peas peas
and carrots
frozen with steamed unseasoned white
rice
just mix it together and the dog eats it
like a champ
you know maybe he's an asian dog i don't
know it's a better meal than i eat
when i was married i come downstairs
anne's making hamburger meat
with rice in it and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
go to the refrigerator
i pull out a couple flour tortillas i
warm them up on the thing
i get a spoon put them in there put some
pico pica in there
roll them up with burritos and she comes
around the corner she goes what are you
eating the dog food for
and i said well what do you mean the dog
food you got that made that for the dog
the dog has stomach issues
i guess you give him hamburger and like
white rice and i was like this is the
[ __ ] that my grandmother would make
now finally she's getting it she's
making the [ __ ] that i want to eat
we were some good friends i was good
friends and have a suit
and my buddy ralph and myself we had
been drinking all goddamn day and we
were peaceful and and we were there
visiting linda
and her husband john i love that [ __ ]
beast is a good word for you to learn
and so we're there but only we had by
the
end of the evening both rob and i were
getting hungry and she ain't offering up
food
you know offer something up you know
we're getting drunk and then
zero there and she's got this mix and
she's mixing it all up
i said rob look she's gonna make it she
got this little scooper like
for melon balls she's making bother oh
she's making us some more dirt rob look
at that we're gonna score now
and john lizzie says no don't get your
go get your mind set up food because
that's for the dog she's getting ready
to feed her dog oh
[ __ ] i said [ __ ] it how come she didn't
want to feed you guys because she wanted
you guys to leave
she was she was drinking with us oh
she's just a bad hostess
she was a bad hostess at night you know
sometimes when they i guess what they
want you to leave there
so so uh i have a house in the desert
and laquinta this guy burned
that is almost like a uh
he lived on the lot at warner brothers
that's how we met him he had enough
money
for an apartment but he was a writer and
he was like
do i want to be a a writer or do i live
in an apartment
so he rents an office in warner brothers
two doors down from my
dressing rooms at two rooms that
connected the two rooms
and we see him and you'd think he was a
writer during the day he looked well put
together
he was living in his office all right so
he would
the guards go around you know they drive
around they check the doors and
everything and he would
hide from them and then make it appear
like i guess he would leave the lot
and then he would either come i don't
know maybe he wouldn't leave the line
and come back in sometimes he would
and he would make it look like he was
leaving hey see you later guys and then
i guess he would [ __ ] come back on
with his changing guards around the
block and he'd make it seem like he was
just riding
you know all night and but he was living
there
so he he's gotten by
in he's in he's he's gotten by like just
hand to mouth you know and he's in
titanic in the movie like
toward the end i mean he's in the water
help us
i mean he he has a line in [ __ ]
titanic
toward the end when before leo the
captain floats away
he's just up in the water help us please
like
the [ __ ] burn man you know so
i invited him to come and play golf in
um in la quinta with me
and i i rarely go there so whatever's
there stays there sometimes i tell them
hey i'm coming you know just give me
some milk
you know cereals all right you know
different stuff so i go in there and
he's sitting with his legs crossed like
this
and he's got a cup of coffee and this
[ __ ] is like macgyver of of
things you know he could take
that [ __ ] fake green [ __ ] right there
make a [ __ ] call out of that
[ __ ] just like
crazy [ __ ] so he's sitting there with
his lace cross big coffee cup and i said
where did you get the milk
it goes oh you had like ready whip in
the
refrigerator whipped cream so he's he
shot the whipped cream in the coffee
and it's it's cream yeah and then i go
where did you get the
uh the biscuits and he goes all the
biscotti you had you had him
up there like he looked at the back they
were left over from when i had this dog
that i gave up
for [ __ ] dog biscuits they were like
peanut butter
long dog biscuits he didn't read the
package or or maybe he did and he's
sitting there and he's
dipping the [ __ ] biscuit in the
coffin and eating the dog biscuits just
like a
like [ __ ] like goddamn joshua
gabor the [ __ ] sit there
just [ __ ] legs crossed with the
coffee where'd you get the
milk oh the whipped cream where'd you
get those biscuits they were up on the
top they even said richard on it because
that dog's name was richard
and he goes oh these dogs that richard
these snacks that richard bought i guess
he was staying here you know i took uh
i was at work there was a female deputy
she saw one of the guys
putting away what she thought was jerky
it was it was jerky for dogs
and she said i want some jerky and he
said no no no you don't want any of this
it's not she's
no no i love jerky let me have you he
says this one's old she's i don't care
let me have
she got she goes oh you're right this is
oh she ate the whole thing
so i went back i had a dog at the time
and i told my wife i said
this is what they did to patty rodriguez
over there at the station and
my son heard me my daughter came home
and
he says hey want some jerky and he gave
her some of the
and she started then she comes up to me
dad she's ready to cry
jr gave me some dog jerky
and i said oh son what am i supposed to
do
you know bad you can't let him get away
with it i said okay
i said start barking like a dog and tell
her you're sorry
hey so so what's a different like a
jerky is
i mean jerky is beef made from dried out
beef right
yeah so what would the difference be in
jerky
what's the difference between a slim jim
which i love by the way you're not
supposed to eat them
yeah oily who knows what the [ __ ] is in
that
that makes it go perfectly round listen
for me to go perfectly round
in whatever [ __ ] skin that is an
abomination but what but i don't need
them all the time
but you know that was a i never told
this story there was a there was a
higher patrolman i used to work at a
store at a liquor store in high school
in canyon country uh and there was a
police officer that would go in there
and he was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they used to have these tubes of
jerky in the front of the thing
and long like that i'd put them in my
cool and walk around
five minutes and then i would put them
back in the tube
but i put them in my ass like like a
straw between my crack
and you know this was in high school so
that it wasn't
you know it fit perfectly
i would walk around for like five
minutes and make a couple sandwiches
with the with the thing sticking out
like a little periscope
you know you know when somebody puts a
face on a pencil and you look at it
everybody everybody's going like this
the pencil has a face
i put that thing in my little pencil
with it with a little pencil like a
little face coming out and then i would
the guy would i go
hey it's ready and the guy i was working
with would pull it out
and put it back in the container what is
this liability
right now did you ever see he's going
there you go how's it going
when you [ __ ] criminals he'd undo the
thing and he [ __ ] pulled one out
and here you go
we would say all right nobody eat out of
this one right here
like when somebody was looking at him
pull him back if you remember put him
back out there that guy would come in
there you [ __ ]
ah what you gotta do is dropping it
you're stealing anything today just
[ __ ] you're like
this guy so we put him in there and then
we play jerky roulette but i think all
of them at some point
had coolo well thankfully
what you said
it was not as bad as the guy that put
cyanide in the tylenol but
oh yeah for for for those times to put
to put a long jerky stick in your
coulomb
and continue the services i'm just
wondering now what was your motivation
let's take something up your food are
you kidding me that's hilarious
there's been a lot there's been a lot of
things you know like they use the same
old chicago
that's an exit not an entrance the uh
but in in that stuff and so whatever is
in the slim jib like if i go to a golf
tournament and sometimes they have like
on one of the holes that have like a
little convenience store set up i think
at cedric's golf room and they have like
like a 7-11 on the thing and you go over
there
and everything's free and uh i'll take
10 i can slim gyms or those things and
put them in
the bag and once a year maybe once a
year
i would eat all 10 like at the same time
but that it's rare because you can eat
them
all the time now but you don't but once
in a while i think when the moon is in
the right oh yeah
frame you sit in there and you watch tv
and eat these things
as a father you know with my daughters
and girl scouts my son played t-ball and
then one year of football
they used to sell cookies and candies
and all this [ __ ]
the best seller was they would sell
those
beef sticks the football team got them
and they were
easy sell easy take them to the station
put them up to everybody wanted to take
them out they were all
cool free too yeah you never got they
started
they started to wrap them i'll only eat
one now if it's wrapped
but but wait these weren't wrapped oh
you're talking about the ones you had
one they weren't wrapped oh yeah the old
days
oh i didn't even think they came in a
tube they came in a tube you could just
pull them out of there well that gives
the story a whole new flavor
so you know back then exactly so in
little league
my grandmother worked at rca over there
on uh roscoe and balboa i ended up
working with her which became the thing
for my show that we worked together
because you know when we started to put
the show idea together they would say
well what what are the things that you
guys did together and i said oh [ __ ] you
know when i was like 20 we worked
together perfect
make a place where we her and i worked
perfect it didn't look staged didn't
look unreal
we worked at the same place and i became
like the boss and she was the worker and
then you have the conflict
and um they would in in little league
they would sell
um there was those chipmunks that used
to that used to sell that
what they call like butter toffee
peanuts oh yeah yeah but they were like
the chip the two
[ __ ] chipmunks or whatever
chipperdale like that but but it had a
chipmunk on the package or whatever
anyways for literally you would sell
butter toffee peanuts
and to this day i have some in the house
i looked at him a couple nights ago i
was going to eat them but they look
they all stick together they look a
little bit gotcha i buy them at the fair
right yeah right so i was
i can't i used to go door-to-door i
[ __ ] hated it i mean
i'm i'm not a door-to-door [ __ ] even
talk to my friends
you stayed at home all weekend you're
not going to want to go door-to-door if
the house was on fire
i would just sit in there and burn it
why don't you call your neighbors i'll
talk to those [ __ ] poo
this [ __ ] sitting burn i'd rather
burn up than knock on my neighbor's dory
can you call 9-1-1
or rather i'd rather die so i don't know
what the
psychology i don't know that's good
fodder for your next session yeah i
don't know why
but i think he knows so my grandmother
would take it to work and come back and
go
here and throw it at me the two pages
were filled out
of like of [ __ ] that
was she sold 250 [ __ ] boxes at work
which is perfect but you really want to
teach me a lesson you would
say i'm not going to do that for you you
have to do something for yourself you're
going to have to go door to door and
sell them what if i don't
then you're not so cut too
funny how things connect
the in saffron ohio the coach martin
passed away
passed away a few years ago and then
that was the one where he gave us
250 worth of car wash tickets to pay for
the batting cage
and the stuff that the players had to
pay for but he didn't tell us that
if you sold no tickets you were still
liable for 250
like you owed them 250 and tell us that
of course why would he tell us
i didn't sell any i didn't even try to
sell then when i go there he goes you
owe me 250
but i for what for these tickets and i
said i didn't sell any tickets yeah but
you're going to use the equipment you're
not going to
sell any of these tickets what do you
think the equipment do you think it's
free i said hey man
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] your equipment i
didn't i'm not giving you [ __ ]
then he went in on me telling me i'm a
quitter and how [ __ ] gets tough i
[ __ ] pack it in
i'm a [ __ ] he likes to see me in 10
years see where i'm at because
you know quitters don't get [ __ ] let's
see where you are in 10 years i'm like
oh yeah [ __ ]
and we're i'm a i'm probably not even
18.
and we're this far away from each other
in in the gym like i still remember
standing had two dudes behind me and he
had the assistant coach behind him and
we're like this
and then we leave and that my room my
two friends were like [ __ ]
they were tripping man i never seen a
student and a teacher
go at it like that like back [ __ ] you
[ __ ] quit [ __ ]
and then i start playing golf and golf
it's it's tough to learn how to play
tough hit the ball sideways didn't know
what i was doing didn't pay i had money
paid for lessons
and i would quit every time it got hard
so they played sometimes i played nine
holes and quit
those guys like where you going ah man
you know i gotta go do something
short story one day i'm leaving and it's
like when someone says
i could hear a voice so i'm driving and
i hear
this voice say every time it gets tough
you pack it in
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and still
remember where i was and i hovered by
the 210 getting under 210
you pack it in i'm like this i said what
the [ __ ] start to think about it
started to go through my life and this
guy was right
i had already started doing stand-up
probably doing stand-up for like five
years but i quit
come back quit come back
so i [ __ ] one day i go over to the
school like and i wait to all the
students leave and all the
baseball players go to the locker room
he's picking up the bases and i'm
walking towards him and he's looking and
he's like
is that my third baseman said coach
what's up and he's like what
what are you doing what's going on and
say man i just i came to tell you that
i'm sorry
you know for the way that i behaved when
i was here what what are you talking
about i remember that day that you and i
uh this and that called me a quitter
well you know what man
you know i apologize to you because
i realized that you were right and i
said and i couldn't go on with my life
unless i came and told you that i was
sorry i don't
think that you know chicanos we'd rather
pretend
that somebody's dead than say sorry
then admit my grandmother had a sister
that she didn't talk to forever they
even looked alike
and one time we saw him at the put it on
my show in the first four episodes
that she saw this woman at the end of
the aisle and she goes this way this way
this way i'm like what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] going on this way this way
this way and i go back and i look
and i [ __ ] i said that lady looks
like you that's my sister charlotte
i said i don't know you have a sister i
don't have a sister
and i'm like wow it looked like a
younger version of my grandmother
[ __ ] didn't even know she had to sit
that's that's my what is it my aunt
it's my aunt yeah and two cents is a
part that's my sister charlotte i didn't
know you had a sister
i don't so when i went and told him that
he said hey did you that's why you
that's why you came down here to tell me
that i said yeah and he puts his hand
out shakes my hand he goes there might
be
hope for you yet and
once i went back to doing stand-up i had
learned the quitter
april 23rd 1984 my birthday
and i had been already away the guys
would see me and i was i wasn't bad
it wasn't entirely bad it wasn't great
still starting
and i went back and i said no matter
what happens i'm not going to quit
and all this happened from april 23rd
1984 whatever all this is for the good
and the bad of whatever
but i don't think that was a lesson i
would have learned
without that interaction which was awful
i felt bad because i was always
respectful of people
and without playing golf i just wouldn't
have had i wouldn't have had anything
happen to me in my life that was
challenging
where i would where i would quit you
know if i was mad at a friend
i wouldn't talk to that person if i was
with some girl didn't work out
wouldn't talk to him like one and one
and done
so up you know still doesn't get me out
of the house
i hear you're a pretty good golfer too
not bad no i'm not and i love it and you
know i used to get mad and throw [ __ ]
but what it did was it gave me a
temperament that i needed for business
and i needed for stand-up that
i wouldn't have learned any other way
guys that throw clubs or get mad or or
never get it together after i would i
would find a way to slow down
play back to the middle or whatever and
it's fun but i don't really keep score
i'm more into the into the temperament
very rarely i still
occasionally get mad but i'm more about
the good
feeling of it because there's a feeling
that goes to the club and when you hit
it and you see where it's going we're
supposed to be going that
is almost i guess would be like if
somebody rubbed your head or tussled
your hair
you know that you feel it in your in
your chest so my grandfather wasn't that
person my grandma wasn't that person
and golf even when i was married like
you know uh
and talking to ann again you know like
10 years after he'll text me and i don't
text her back it's like i just
i don't i don't know if you can be proud
of i want to be friends with it's not
that i
don't appreciate it but i just have a
hard time
almost like i just shouldn't say but
going back
because it's just you know when you
answer my texts i'm happy i know i've
done it
like i just don't don't think that you
know
yeah no i mean that's powerful story
dude like it going back like
you're what 20 24 25 you said you went
back and apologized like
not a lot of 24 or 25 year olds would
have done that i think it sort of speaks
to what's happened to you since then
that you
did do that and it's always funny those
kind of like time bomb
truths or whatever yeah that we have
where it's i don't know i just i don't
know i got to go back
and thank dr robert morneau the guy that
gave me the intelligence or the
the ability to see in the night stalker
case the stuff that i was seeing
that was making him a sexual deviant
that i could recognize
and what did that doctor do wait a
minute sorry i took two semesters at cal
state from this guy he was a professor
uh dr robert morneau retired fbi agent
and i took two semesters he required
more work than any professor i've ever
had
of advanced criminal investigation
pertaining to sex crimes
and so he's the one that taught me about
understanding the ability to listen
and to recognize things that because
somebody wants to see the fear in
somebody's eyes that's a sign of sexual
deviancy wow
you know the the way they do things they
the guy if i give you
uh a condo and mammoth it's snowing
outside you have a flickering fireplace
no cell phones no outside detractors no
kids no bill collectors nobody contact
me just you
and that special member of society that
you want to be with
music you're both out of the shower
white bearskin rug hors d'oeuvres and
wine or beer on it sounds like that's
going to turn into a night of wrong
adulterated sexual intercourse
that's because that's sex to you but now
i got a guy that can't afford to go to
mammoth
and he doesn't have another member of
society he's up in the hills of malibu
and he's got his own member in his own
hand
and he's got a book of matches he just
set the hills of malibu on fire
and now he's in an act of masturbation
because
he's a pyromaniac and that's sex to him
so i learned all this stuff from bob
morneau
and it was all good so
after the case was during the case i had
permission from the department
to go get him and bring him on board to
help us out he was on sabbatical in
greece
after the case was all over with
everything said and done
he was back i got to go back and thank
him
for giving me the knowledge to work the
case
he's the one that made it give me
another example of of deviancy
i think that's a i mean that's a pretty
pretty good one man
yeah like you know people that like
fires but i think they
but but also let's say since my
knowledge of uh serial killers
is that if one thing they do have in
common is
abusing animals jeffrey dahmer would
kill a dog
and put the head on a stick or leave the
head on the fence so everybody
could see it but a disrespect of animals
or hurting
other kids or i think primarily
animals though because you could tell a
lot about a person
he looked he he said he asked how many
people
how many guys in this class men and
women
most of them were cops uh but cal state
l.a just
so he says how many people have been in
here went to a burglary call
where somebody's burglarized the house
you're just gonna take a report and you
see somebody is defecated
in someplace other than the toilet
either in a bedroom or in the living
room
just a big old honking uh piece of
mierdo right there
load right there and and he says you
know and i raised my hand because i had
seen that before
and he says okay he says if you're
looking for the hype burglar you're
barking up the wrong tree
you find the local sexual deviate he
went in there to take a [ __ ]
while he's done now incidental to being
here now i'll steal
but it was the fact that he wanted to go
take a dump richard himself told us
uh up in the sierra madre case he asked
me he says hey do you see where i took a
dump
i see he didn't take a dump of that
please yeah i did i said the only place
there was a dump he stopped me says by
the bushes
and i said yeah he says that was me wow
you know so he was a sexual deviant but
he knows that that wasn't in the thing
so he said to you because you were on
him
you were right now we're just talking
now you're talking he said you see where
i took a dump
yeah and and he goes you didn't take a
dump in there
and he goes yeah not in the house
outside
yeah i did he said i said there was
nobody in there by the bushes
and i said yeah and there was by the
bushes right outside the front right out
the bedroom window there was a big [ __ ]
big turd there i just thought it was a
dog
and why would somebody do that sign of
sexual deviancy you know
i i've interviewed prostitutes you know
and
working a hooker murder where we're
we're looking for a john that used to
get a little rough you know maybe
because it was a hooker that died and so
we're talking to this hooker and she's
sitting there you got anybody get from
it he says no
anybody treats you badly well frenchie
frenchie gets a little pissed off and i
can't perform
so what do you mean he said well he
likes to come over and he just wants me
to dump on him
well i'm thinking dump on him you know
maybe tell stories you know give me sad
stories
dump all my sorrows on and so my partner
looks there he said what do you mean
dump
she says yeah you like me to dump on him
you know [ __ ] right here
he liked her to [ __ ] on his chest and
then she ends up her story saying
but he really wasn't a bad guy he had
this patch right here in his arms
something unified school district the
guy worked for the schools
whoa and he wore the patch to the hooker
yeah
yeah he was a janitor a bus driver or
something
for the school what's the psychology of
that i don't know they
ask a doctor why you know because
it's a deviancy right it's a
demonstration is that
another deviant necrophilia where people
like to
have sexual intercourse with dead bodies
you know and
and mourinho just says for purposes of
this class
sex is whatever makes you feel good
that was his definition for sex whatever
makes you feel good because what turns
you
you on may not turn somebody else on
but also has to trace back to childhood
no i don't trade
i don't know where it stems from how
they get it how they get their
information how they gather it
i don't know i mean it's too it's too
easy to say it goes back to childhood
but but
there is i think some characteristics
of a certain type of behavior i think in
in
in serial killers that they were abusive
richard was abused a lot of them have
been been abused uh what was the
what was one of the guys i think even
one of them i think
wasn't the golden state guy wasn't he a
police officer or
yes he wasn't saying keller was a police
officer
for a while yeah
i i don't know man that's i believe
in that nah don't quote me on this
last week i believe i told grant
i i was here early and i was studying
because i know
oh yeah i noticed you liked the serial
killer i needed the crime the drama
so i was studying i was surprised you
didn't bring it up but i wanted to be
prepared for you
so studying on rodney alcala that's
right
because he passed away he passed away at
age 77.
so the game killer the dating game
killer and looking
reading about him i believe he was
abused as a child
as well he was abused as a child
um but also he wasn't
unattractive no okay so what ted bundy
was not on the track there was not
unattractive when he was on the dating
game
he did yes but the girl backed out she
wanted she didn't want to go out with
her as a freak because she got [ __ ]
creeped out by him
so he would pretend he was a
photographer yes
he was in good shape had long hair not a
bad looking dude
and he would go to huntington beach he
would go to different
areas where women were and he would ask
if he could take pictures with
of them and he said that he was a
photographer for
a certain kind of magazine that he could
have been back then
he could have been and those girls would
say yeah sure and then take him
in his car and then you know take him
back to the place and he got a bunch of
pictures in there yeah
is it like 70s 80s is that what he was
saying some people
said sophie dickman testified that
richard romero was quite a handsome
young man
when he pulled his hair back and he wore
a suit
it looked like he was a miami dope
dealer
you know he was ready to go out saturday
night thin high cheekbones
some people thought he was very
good-looking they did and you could see
where
like if a guy is uh charismatic
where you don't get put off initially by
someone being creepy so if a guy is
charismatic like rodney you call out a
good
had a good rap and and you look at
richard
ramirez you wouldn't necessarily be put
off initially so
that's his kind of defense where if i
can get close enough
ted bundy or pretending your car doesn't
work
or like in silence of the lamb you know
can you help me put this
uh couch into the mark tomorrow he's got
a broken arm
which i think that guy should have won
an academy award for his well that was
great
buffalo bill right i forgot that you
should have won a should have won an
academy award
ted levine ted levine aaron from
downtown and he does and he does
uh he was on some show he was in the
movie he too tbs
yeah but i mean for that performance
didn't get an academy award
i don't know who beat them that year but
yeah
i don't know so um
i was watching woodstock 99
on on hbo have you seen it no but i've
had friends uh recommend is it new just
can't
i think it's brand new i've seen it
maybe five times already
because of the psychology of
so this is 99 before cell phones
[Music]
and they even say like woodstock
69 was more of a
aberration of like it you know they
didn't make any money
they had this concert in new york
woodstock new york colorwood stocks they
had all these things the fence came down
people were swimming in water there
wasn't any porta-potties i don't think
they were swimming in the lake doing
whatever
and it's just drugs and hanging out and
tough circumstances and backed up
traffic and trying to sell sandwiches
and
all those things but somehow it became
an iconic
three days yeah lining in a bottle
lightning yeah
and then woodstock 99 same guys try to
do it
they're older now before cell phones
and they book all of these acts and i
mean there's a lot of people there
there might be 500 000 people there
and i remember the girl so there's a lot
of
a lot of white guys 22 25
with backward hats and all that angst at
drinking
they had some cure security peace patrol
guys like in
yellow shirts i say peace patrol and
they were supposed to
ones that go around those guys were so
[ __ ] hot
wouldn't let you try to sell water for
four dollars a bottle
beer and water were the same price and
then
those guys were like [ __ ] this man and
then it was on an old
air force base and the [ __ ] heat from
the sidewalk it's brutal
and they already have issues
it's six hours they're six hours into
the first day
and they're already having issues and
moby the guy moby the
dj the artist he says something i wanted
to ask you about he said
you know and it's and it's true he goes
he goes from years of being in clubs and
years of performing
he goes we got there and i got off of
the
bus or his ride and he got out and he
says
there's something in here that just
[ __ ] doesn't feel right
and they and he said what was that he
goes you know just years of performing
like i can tell already
if i get there what it's going to be
like and so can i
i can tell from 42 years of
at least 30 of them for solid working i
can tell in the room
if there's going to be a problem or it's
going to be good i can tell if there's
going to be an issue with somebody and
sometimes i call people in i said hey
man
there's some guy out there that's
talking can you have somebody to
can't find them just well i can hear
them just [ __ ] go out there and
define them
sometimes they remove people but i tell
them before even when i let a guy go
before me
you can hear somebody yelling out
calling the guy i said hey man there's a
dude out there
that's talking we trying to find him
well [ __ ] fine we mean you're
trying to fight him i can hear him from
in here
how can you not find him you could kind
of hear it and he says
there's something in there not right so
what happens is
they start to paw at women you know it's
all confined and the mosh pit in the
front they put girls up now they're
starting to rip
girls tops off and sexually assaulting
girls
and just this lord of the flies
mentality and
they're in there and ripping tops off
and girls are doing it
in the beginning they're doing it on
their own and then they're showing that
you know the chest and they cover it the
radio station there has
the radio station banner and two girls
and the dj's up there and they're
showing their tits and it's like show
your tits and
it becomes that for like a day
two days and even rosie perez walks out
there in a dress
and they're like show your tits show
your the whole
crowd is chanting she's like i'm not
gonna show my tits like [ __ ] boo
and they're like you can just it's just
[ __ ] this
mob and you can see
and then you see interactions with
people that go i don't know who put this
[ __ ] lineup together
but you have like jewel and you have uh
a moby alanis morissette and then you
have
atlantis morissette limp biscuit
[ __ ] rage against the machine
metallica those are the last four acts
of of saturday so atlantis morrison goes
up there
and she's singing like isn't it ironic
and
[ __ ] they're not into it and you can
see it the [ __ ] guys are like
they're [ __ ] just like shut the [ __ ]
up they're just
[ __ ] just and you can see it in her
face you can see it in her face
and and i know the look on somebody's
face when they're like [ __ ] get me
the [ __ ] out of here
and she's got to play she'll get paid
she can't
walk off and sometimes you do walk off
i've walked off
and said [ __ ] it there's nothing you can
do at some point
you're lost yeah you know and
you can see it on her face and she's
kind of looking down
and she's singing but half-assed singing
and then she's done
she goes i love you guys so much you
could tell being
[ __ ] puts a microphone down
she's out and then other people are
talking and they show
jewel was like the next day and she says
immediately when i get out there
i'm like what can i play that these
[ __ ] won't
like just turn on me and you can see her
standing up in front of the mic and they
show her face and i
don't think i've ever seen a performer
with that look on their face like what
the [ __ ]
am i doing here and what do i got to do
to get the [ __ ] out of here like just
this look of like
panic it's just an incredible performer
but you just see
what you don't see it just this look
like you see her talking to her
guitar player like what the [ __ ] are we
gonna do and she's done
and then limbiskit goes out there and
the bass player walks out
and he's like this from the beginning
so they're like he set the tone by going
like that
and then it just
went got got worse and worse and then
they
went to him and said like they try to
you know calm everybody down and he's
like [ __ ] that he didn't do it
and they were and he said if you're
trying to blame
fred durst the biscuit he did what
[ __ ] limb biscuit does like if you
pay somebody to perform he was doing
what he was performing
yeah so then red hot chili peppers are
one night
i think the last night and during the
day you know that that shoot in
columbine that year
and this this these two dudes are
selling like you're giving away candles
like little little candles like this and
you can sign a petition against shooting
in schools and make schools safer which
which makes sense
and they got this african-american dude
the whitest sounding dude
ever and he's like just join us tomorrow
take this candle and
tomorrow at eight o'clock we're gonna
have a vigil
so then to cut to the next person they
go i don't know who had the [ __ ] idea
to give out [ __ ] candles because what
did they do
they lit everything on fire
so damn
they start [ __ ] tearing down the
[ __ ] monitors
there's three mothers they start tearing
the [ __ ] down they built a
peace wall that that that kids painted
that week
and the wall goes you know it's pretty
long distance
they [ __ ] start kicking down the wall
and tearing it down
now they take the plywood and they're
have dudes surfing on it while them
biscuits up there
people are holding the plywood and dudes
are dancing on the plywood
and they fall through the plywood it
breaks now they're sexually assaulting
women and pulling them over and pawing
at them
and some nasty [ __ ] that's going on in
there no but but again at a time where
no cell phones i don't think you could
do i'd like to think that that wouldn't
happen now because
you'd be held responsible for your
behavior
if they try to identify it like in the
cat like in the capital yeah but but
now they're lighting [ __ ] on fire and
now the red hot chili peppers are out
there and you see
three [ __ ] huge fires with embers
going in the air you see the guy walk
over
he's talking to anthony keita's the lead
singer and he's like hey uh
you know try to get these people and
what do they do they play fire by jimmy
henry
that's pretty rock and roll and they're
out and then they leave but
it it's it's [ __ ] mayhem and you know
they even say like you know just because
woodstock was
lightning in a bottle and they did it in
and the temp the temperament was
different in people that 99
they were out of their [ __ ] minds and
i'm not sure if it's ever
gotten back to being out there but but
they just did lollapalooza
yeah and i saw similar headlines where i
was like
miley cyrus fans were freaking out
because like you know playboy cardi or
something was right before and they're
like i'm not ready for this crowd and
the
playboy cardi crowd was like i don't
want to be here for my [ __ ] cyrus
and no riots as far as i know but at
least
because dmx god rest his soul had a song
that you know has the n-word in it and
even the people that talk to this
reporter african-american guy and he's
like
you know i was everybody was wondering
if he was gonna do that song
and he did it and it's a call and
response like
you say it they say it back he does the
words they say it back
and then the african reporter is there
talking and he's like
you give license to everybody to say
that word he goes even if you had
friends that
you didn't know were n-word sayers he
says like your n-word sayers
they're all doing it and i mean if
there's 250 000 people there
they were all doing it he goes so what
if you're an african-american person in
the crowd
and you hear this how do they treat you
when you
walk by i mean all of it makes sense
yeah just once you've like activated
that mode but in that
in that call and response they were that
guy dmx might have had the best set
of anybody because he went early i think
james brown started it friday
at like 12 30 james brown brother
brother james did it they probably got
down james brown man to show respect to
james brown
but it just deteriorated to the point
where
you know you can't imagine the liability
somebody died
this dude that was there talking about
his friend they got separated
his friend died they were treating him
for a heart attack he was odin they like
paddled them when he was odin they don't
paddle a person that's odin
they thought he was having a heart
attack or some [ __ ] dead
and he's like how do you how do you go
with it to a concert with a dude
and then you have to call his parents
and say hey man
you know you wait until the movie comes
up then you tell parents say watch the
movie
so 23 years later so in 79 there was a
there was a festival
uh for two days at the coliseum called
the world music festival
and uh almost everybody was there van
halen aerosmith
ufo black sabbath molly hatchet
blackfoot
boomtown rats scorpions every [ __ ]
you
everybody everybody's there we saw one
woman like high naked
nobody touched her nobody tripped out
nobody tried to grab her nobody you know
you just look at her she's stripping
whatever
whatever she's tripping on and it's
crazy to think that i was at a festival
in 79 [ __ ] old man
and then you see the one in 99 and
they're [ __ ] just
they even said like this woman this girl
said they had three dudes had her by one
leg three about another one and they she
heard somebody say rip her apart
oh jesus i mean what the [ __ ]
but it's all crazy whatever society like
they're like what
what are what are in these people that
they don't think that society
is for them listen i mean the [ __ ]
societies
is bad but it ain't bad for a 22 25 year
old [ __ ] white dude ain't that bad
it's worse for people
that are without a home that lose their
[ __ ] light you know
sometimes they get wound up with
everybody else they're wound up and
they're drinking and there's no
not drinking if you're drinking
aggravates then the conditions are bad
they're
you know you see one guy jump on top of
a cop car and a riot
then pretty soon you'll see 10 people up
on that cop car
they just get wound up in the frenzy and
then they go yeah yeah i could be
talking out of my ass here but i'm
pretty sure i've read that like in big
crowd events like that too it's like
they've done research and like the part
like the part of your brain that holds
like the ego or why not like
it's it deactivates a bit and you just
go with the flow like you're barely even
thinking to some degree you're part of
this crowd there's a guy in there
skinny dude and he's like hey i'm not
anything
like that and i did it he's like i was
surprised that myself
that [ __ ] mild-mannered dude goes i
did it and they're just
and at the end now they go to the
concessions
and they take over the concessions and
they steal everything that's there
they tear down the [ __ ] boots they
tear down
all the t-shirts they open up a truck
that has frozen [ __ ] pretzels in
there
they start throwing frozen pretzels at
everybody and at the end you just see
all these burnt out
frozen berries and it just they said it
just became like the symbol of
that [ __ ] this four dollar water
[ __ ] and they
the pop the porta potties were
overflowing
and people are mud sliding in the water
it's [ __ ] water and they're in there
man what the all in a all in a festival
all in that you have to watch and let me
know what you think
i'm watching follow by your face until
you see it
because i i'm interested in that do i'm
not a psychologist but i'm interested in
the psychology of
why people behave way too maybe maybe
because of myself maybe because of the
way i act i'll try to [ __ ]
diagnose myself so you know when i had
my eye thing which is better now
uh the dude came and did it at my house
the optometry
at your house they do great uh
uh i love the way this doctor worked too
went up on me
came fast held his bone down puts his
goes i'm gonna numb your eye
your eye your eye this [ __ ]
comes with a needle
we do it on the balcony because the
light's better than the belly of the
first time
and then he leans up against this
cheekbone and he's like i'm pressing
against your bone
and then he shoots it and then it numbs
my eye then he takes a
lid clip and turns it up under and cuts
into it you feel anything can't you can
you feel them [ __ ] with your eye but
then he cuts it and drains it
and you're just like all right cut the
thing puts it down put this on your eye
goes away you know better and
immediately better
and then the other doctor that was there
started to say he goes hey um
you you ever uh you ever you go out and
say no i don't really
i don't really know how much you know he
goes well you know do you go to
restaurants
no not not a lot you stay in a lot yeah
he goes uh you know
i guess he would start talking about
like lexapro like um
you know for depression yeah for
depression yeah it's a very common
antidepressant yeah
so i've never taken an antidepressant
before in my life and uh
and then he starts telling i never even
thought about it and then i
i i go uh huh it goes well
you know i said you know can you
prescribe it you want to try it i said
i said i don't know man i don't know
what you know i'm [ __ ] chicano i
don't know what depression
feels like i mean it's just i think it's
kind of inherent in
in all of us that you almost don't want
to go outer i don't know
i love going out i love people
there you go so there you go
counterpoint so
i've been taking it for should have been
a week
oh nice yeah yeah i've been on lexapro
before i know
a number of people have been on lexapro
i think it takes for me i felt it right
away for a lot of people it takes
i think even weeks like you know what up
it's like an effect
yeah yeah yeah but yeah i don't think
you mean
i think i feel better but i don't go out
i was supposed to golf later on today
which if i do which i have to invited
these guys it would be something that i
wouldn't not
necessarily would have done like at five
four thirty or five
because i would have talked myself out
of it so i think
if i if this can help me from talking
myself out of going out
that's that would be a big hurdle
because i would be like uh
i would be like i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
just about a two beer show i'm gonna
go out and then you talk yourself out of
it which you you've never done that but
did you do that oh all the time
to this day and i mean there's there's a
world too i'm constantly trying to
untangle what's
like you know what is some like weird
sort of like maladaptive behavior or
something like i want to get rid of and
what's like
just kind of my preferences because i'm
like you i'm a homebody
but a party was like should i want to go
out so i know exactly
there's a world with lex pro just makes
you way happier to hang out at home all
the time
but yeah the message from uh
pagan posted something on uh
instagram nice little thing about the
show that we had here and meeting who
did that
pagan your friend oh angelo angelo and
uh
he said you got to get out and have
breakfast
and i said i'd love to and he said see
if you can drag george out here with you
i said there you go i'll talk so hit him
let's go i think we should go before we
do the show
let's go let's go next monday before we
do the show all right so i'm playing
with with angelo
when today today and uh
ryan who i met with uh eddie van halen i
wrestled so
so eddie van halen brought ryan he goes
hey can i bring you like a bud
i say yeah i've been my buddy and uh
when he passed we decided that we were
going to stay friends because eddie
brought us together very difficult to
have any
go man you know because you meet a guy
and you're like man
you know like you and i we just
initially clicked you meet a guy you
clicked forget about that he's one of
your idols
growing up but that he just likes the
things that you like
and he's maybe he's he was home a lot i
was home a lot but golf or whatever
was great went on trips and stuff but
you know you can meet somebody
you can know somebody forever and not
feel a connection or you can meet
somebody like you and i
you just met sure and you're right from
the beginning
yeah yeah absolutely so are you still on
it or do you uh you know i'm on uh
so i went off it for a while i took it
for maybe six seven months felt like it
didn't
work as well for me anymore and then
went into um now i'm on zoloft
okay which is like fine not only i mean
it's always a dance
there's a there's a line in a movie and
this is for gil
it was a wonderful movie that icecube
and uh chris tucker
did and it was called friday
oh yeah a wonderful movie it's a great
movie the first time i saw it
i laughed i couldn't believe i was
laughing this hard
and one of the famous lines is i know
you don't smoke weed
but today's friday and you ain't got
[ __ ] to do
and we're gonna get uh [ __ ] up oh my
god
so gil i know you don't smoke weed
i know this but it's monday
so this is called
bliss for the listening audience george
just pulled out like a willy wonka grab
bag
yeah okay so um can you define what
bliss is for us uh sure so looking at is
the doses
bliss pen uh so this would be like a
vaporizer
pen uh disposable i believe nine two uh
so 50 doses so 50 hits you can take off
it
uh nine to one thc to cbd ratio you're
familiar with that at all
so thc like the psychoactive stuff cbd
is the stuff that has a lot more just
like medical
yeah benefits you can like rub it on
your knee if it hurts uh
so that's that's this bad boy but that
supposed to make you happy is that is
that happening yeah i mean i think it's
a little bit branding it's not like
it'll get you high and you'll probably
be happy because of it but that's okay
gil there's option one right number one
uh number two uh super pure
cbd oil uh so this is pure
cbd oil i don't think any any thc in
here
no so this is pure um you know you can
sort of take it for
aches and pains does that prepare you
stick a beef stick up your cooling wait
a minute nothing
nothing will prepare you this this one
will
uh gil this is our third choice all
right so we have the docest arouse it's
the same brand as the other one is the
bliss
that want to put like a beef stick go
right between your oil
there you go uh same deal 50 doses just
a little bit more thc than the other one
all right
all right this one what else we got all
right sorry i hit that in front of you
relief uh very similar uh two to one thc
to cbd what's that so
this one so the last one was ten to one
this is two yeah which is
[ __ ] like that which doesn't
necessarily mean a [ __ ] ton it just
means maybe
it could be way less cbd than the thc
but this one does this one this one make
the beef
the beef squasher squash it won't be
squashed when you're when you're on that
but is this is this good
is that ten to one is good or not ten to
one is strong or not ten to one will be
it will be probably about as strong as
any of these but it won't have the cbd
so it won't have
the other sort of effects a rouse
i'm not i'm not the next expert i just
play one on the podcast um
here we got two to one thc to cbd so
this one does have a lot of cbd in it as
well as thc so you're just okay you get
a little bit of everything in here
this one is called this would be for
relief so i think they want like for
example if you're like you know
hanging out at home and oh my my knees
killed me and my shoulder's killing me
that might be a good one
let's put some ointment on my on my
finger this morning there you go did it
work
yeah okay you could throw this in the
trash you could do whatever
i'm just gonna put it over there because
i know you have
you know problems with pain
next up i'm not saying take it yeah i'm
not saying anything all right i'm just
saying well then maybe
officially i'm not i'm not going to use
it i'm not going to take it okay i'm
going to put it right
me down right there switzerland right in
the middle right there and there we go
uh so calm another doses pen
it won't even stay up that's oh this one
so the one arouse
the the the beef one there that'll
that's a ten to one thc to cbd
this is a one to ten thc to see this one
is mostly cbd yeah
so in terms of your pains and whatnot
and not want to get too [ __ ] up this
is probably your guy yeah
so i will if you want to switch along
that i can't believe that you use the f
word
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's a christian
part there's one more uh
and then lastly sleep so this is a eight
to one thc to cbd
and probably my guess would be that it's
uh in
indica which if that means there's
indicas and their sativas are the two
sort of
varieties of thc indica the general idea
is like
in the couch it's the relaxing one
hanging out at home
sativa that's the more like heady high
creative whatever
in the couch in the couch that's that
you know that's what that's how they
explain it to me because nobody could
ever tell
what's the difference between indica
sativa they go indica in the couch
exactly so this one has a good amount of
thc but will probably be a good knockout
you know i took a little hit of that
bliss one man and i'm already feeling
feeling pretty blissed out
so it's starting to get out of focus i'm
a little bit i'm a little to me
a little blurry yeah i'm a little bit
tripping just on that little thing
okay and these are oh there's more yeah
okay i can't
i can be here for you know what my eyes
are go at eight i think the lexapro is
making me
not be able to see i just went the eye
doctor before coming down here today
what do you say uh one of my eyes is
starting to say this is the dentist
it's changed sir give me a new
prescription in just one eye
yeah the other eye is just as strong
oh so this is um flour they say i think
it's just a dropper
actually what let me see a little
dropper i don't even know i think you
might this would probably like rip off
the tab
and drop it tabs on your tongue but this
is so it's like
cbd oil i'm pretty sure is what this is
and it's sativa so that's a
it's jack harrow which is actually a
really popular strain i know uh seth
rogen calls it his working weed i've
heard that before
uh it's good for the creativity uh you
know when you're writing your novel it
is really
that and it hits everyone different but
i know for a lot of people they do like
that
all right so this one's got some more
oil this is a
girl scout cookie which is a hybrid uh
and also girl scout yeah girl scout
cookie and also super popular does it
taste like girl scout cookie um
i don't know if the oil will but i've
i've smoked the actual one before and it
it tastes very like all right so open
that up so people
that how how do you so i see what is
if you look on the very end there's like
a little tab but i'm pretty sure you
pull off
and then you can like probably squeeze
that to like blot out some drops
you don't put them in your eye doesn't
that you do not put that
that would that would probably require
another optometrist
i'm trying to think of it looks like
what we
rather drive them home no but but um
let's say this let's say let's say i
mean
one of the things about this podcast
that sticks in my mind
is when be real was here and you were
here and we were talking about first of
all you were you were surprised on how
knowledgeable
be real was on
everything knowledgeable personable
articulate
i was thoroughly impressed how much he
was like entrepreneur i don't know if he
dropped that term but that is that they
call it
we people who do the weed okay yeah i
just looked at one of his things today
he was uh he was rapping
and saw a little bongo player and he was
rapping he's good
his voice that nasal that he said that
nate like they said hey man i think
he was [ __ ] around with it and found
it the 90-year show that
we went to see you up in west hollywood
they're playing music
and there's this one song going out and
i'm not into the rap stuff you know i
i'm an oldies guy but this thing's going
on but i i was a musician
and so i like that hey this this and my
daughter says daddy like i said yeah
this guy this this stuff is good she
goes
that's be real oh [ __ ] and it was one of
his songs
insane in the membrane i don't know what
is it
rock star is trying to be on rock yeah
[Laughter]
um okay anything else
yeah we got we got plenty okay okay
you know grape ape so
i've not heard of this one before but
it's uh it's a great bit more oil
um it says evening and oh it says indica
so this is probably just an indica too
okay one for
the evenings let's talk about when when
you were
an officer uh-huh but you didn't you
didn't pull anybody over you
you were you were uniformed you were
beautiful sorry okay
let's talk about when you were when you
were uniform how different was your
was your job being uniform as being a
detective
oh difference in night and day when
you're in uniform
you're essentially what they call arrest
oriented so
you got criminals you arrest them and
that's all you care about you're taking
bad guys off the streets
when you're a detective you're
prosecution oriented
so now they're in custody or the
report's been written now you're worried
about
getting them prosecuted so it's a whole
different did you know that
no i didn't know what this is it's a
whole different game and then the
sheriff's
what are the what is the sheriff's
jurisdiction we have
uh because andy griffith was like he
couldn't go to mount pilot
no this there he could only be in
mayberry there is no document between
us and lapd we're both uh
two of the largest agencies in the
united states today
and we do everything the same type of
police work
we have patrol we have i believe it's
now up to 22
different substations we are responsible
for patrolling
all the unincorporated areas of los
angeles county
to include incorporated cities that
contract with the sheriff's department
so let us say like the city of
compton they're an incorporated city
they don't have their own police
department they did have their own
police department one time
they chose to pull away from that for
whatever reason they had
at that time and they've asked the
sheriff's department to step on in so
now they have a contract
with the sheriff's department so we do
their police work they don't have any
more compton police
no okay i think in a in a biggie tupac
uh
documentary at that time they did have
compton police and i think they may have
yes
just for corruption and yes
there were some problems and some cities
let us say hawthorne police department
they have their own police department
they're an incorporated city
but whenever they have an
officer-involved shooting or a murder
then they bring in sheriff's homicide to
do it because it's a specialty
interesting
and we do that okay so let's say
hawthorne they're more into the
just maintaining peace they're more into
regular patrol
regular patrols so yeah and if they have
a murder
they're not equipped they're they're not
the people that you would want
no they don't have to make it the right
way they just don't have the manpower
and they don't have the time
they don't have the time to dick to
dedicate
to the murder itself it takes it it's
it's not like tv
it takes hours and hours and a lot of
dedication you have to have the
logistical power to
wherewithal to do it so
when somebody gets killed and you know
he ran to new york
well you tell i just tell my people hey
i need to go to new york well
here it is go you don't have the ability
to do that
in a smaller city there they still have
everyday crime that they have to worry
about
they don't have the time to dedicate to
murder investigations okay so
um gianni versace
yes he was was murdered on the steps of
his of his uh
mansion in miami yes he had gotten out
walked down
no bodyguard i think he had security but
he did didn't take security
there's a there's a kid from you know
san diego andrew cunanan
probably a sociopath murder what is a
psychopath
social social path liar made his life
bigger than it was said he came for
everybody
had a different story for everybody else
sure um
[Music]
knight was didn't see his mom's dad in
the philippines i think his dad was
almost the same way a trait that his dad
had was arrested
left the united states fled couldn't
come back to united states
but then he the kunan had to kill
somebody in
minneapolis uh somebody he was kind of
dating
went over there killed him killed a
friend wrapped him up in the body
the thing they thought then he then he
moved to chicago
and had a he was kind of like a guy that
would cool with older
older people so now you have a murders
in two different
uh cities maybe three always shot up
shot at like a
funeral like a cemetery caretaker took
his car along the way so you have three
murders
and i think in jurisdictions back then
they had a flyer that they
had made in miami and and
the for whatever reason the fbi in miami
or the police
didn't put it out like in gay clubs or
things like that like
3 000 of them they probably would have
who knows would have caught them
before because he was still going out
but then you know he walked up on
versace
never saw it coming and then shot him
and then he went into some
caretakers a lot of people rolled over
on him once he got versace
yeah yeah and i don't know anything
about the story he had beef with versace
or what was the
you know what mattered there i don't
remember all i remember is during that
case
i was contacted by the news media they
wanted to ask they wanted to interview
me a few times
on the versace case especially how it
would be going what they would be doing
and there was no doubt i remember the
last time they interviewed me
excuse me i said i believe they'll
happen within three days now
you were closing in on them and there
was enough information there so they
were
they were very competent they were doing
what everything was right
and the pressure of the world was on him
because it had worldwide media attention
yes because of him being mr versace so
um
i think they may have met at a club in
san francisco briefly
depends on who i think they may have
crossed paths but
to him it was a bigger thing than it was
like he would say to his friends oh i
met versace last night and he invited me
to his fashion show do you know if
either one of them like those beef
sticks
i think maybe going by the way that
kunan was living he might have
he might have gone to the liquor store
and got a couple of
the flamboyant uh the fabulous beef
sticks that i was
seasoning myself but but uh
uh i think yeah i think seasoning but
yeah in someone's mind how they become
fixated on somebody
you know like a mean higher patrolman
if i don't think if the high patrolman
would have been allegedly nicer to us i
would have i would have put those
those sticks in my cooldown that's the
one part of the story that was elected
it was if he was nicer to you you know
what i
always i always i always tell cops treat
people the way you'd like to be treated
see they say right see hey you know for
a reason
i i i know some i know some guy that i
consider a very good friend now
he told me for you could learn hey
but but also he never went and tried a
different flavor either
and like 20 years later he's like why
why doesn't any beef stick taste as good
as the ones from back i remember in the
old days yeah
this one was in the open container okay
this one looks
like something you leave at the a sample
you leave at the doctor's
what is that one oh we got another piece
of paraphernalia hey gil i can't see up
close anymore what is this
no i don't know yeah well well i wear
glasses
i can't see uh the legs protect you i
said i think
first time i first thing okay
probably about 45 years of age i went to
go get lasik
45 pretty close i would i did that lasik
surgery
and i remember telling the doctor he
said doc you can do this on saturday
morning
i said how long is it going to take
because uh
my eyes need to be clear right i'm on
call
and yeah he says okay he says well
normally i'd maybe come back on monday
so i'd
but he says we'll do years first thing
in the morning on saturday come back
five o'clock in the afternoon we'll take
a look
so my daughter drove us down her my wife
had it done too
and so my wife drove us my daughter
drove us down here in the morning
had it done she drove his back i went
back that afternoon saturday afternoon
and they took the patches off my eye and
it worked it was beautiful
it was beautiful i could see it was
great i told my daughter give me the
keys to the car
she says that i'll drive i said give me
the keys in the car
i got it you're not going to be you're
not going to be with me tonight if i get
called out on a murder
give me the keys to the car she gave me
the keys to the car we drove out i got
to the first signal
and i started screaming is it red is it
green is it red or is it green
and they started screaming and i just
started laughing oh man
uh so by the way this is a it's a pen i
wasn't sure if it was at first but
there's another sort of like vape pen
that is 93 percent cbd so mostly cbd
then on psychoactive stuff but uh
a lot of thc or sorry a lot of cbd but
that was a little more
okay so that'll be good um i have to
find out i have to find out when my
when my balm is coming out you know
because
yours work good too it works the only
drawback to yours was
it it smelled like vicks you know so if
you're trying to keep it a secret
i think i think we're trying to convince
vicks to buy it before it comes out but
but uh no i think it it works it works i
gave it to someone who's a musician very
famous in
miami that asked for refills and i don't
think i would ever
refill anybody but i'm not a pharmacy
but i did for him
because you know but it even comes with
its own cradle
okay so i'm going to use i'm going to
use two of these
and we'll talk about it next week do you
want do you want any of this all right
so you can take part i'm going to use
the bliss because
of the alexa pro maybe i'm going to use
the bliss
and i'm going to use the sleep
which i have one right here i think you
ought to use your rods and let us go buy
you some beef sticks
you know what i'm going to use
and then next quarterback and the next
week
i'm gonna come with some beef sticks
that everybody can enjoy at your leisure
i'm gonna go to costco and buy the same
ones i'll make sure those things are
vacuum sealed yeah they've gotta be
jimmy johns
um and the sleep one on wait
this one is do a little research
take notes when you're on make sure we
get good data here relief
okay i'm gonna try the bliss
and the sleep one then
we'll talk about it next next week
sounds good all right we got a little
time if you want to do any uh yeah let's
do something
do voicemails or articles is that cool
and all voicemails all right we'll start
with voicemails throw in the cans uh and
cool news i
know we talked about this a little bit
but um so this episode will be airing
august 9th
and uh during that week we will be
featured on the amazon music
times square billboard what so this art
will be the
the girl going to be on there too we had
to submit it before we had the gail art
unfortunately so gil you will not be
there
um but i mean i didn't know this before
we started doing the production you can
get podcasts on amazon music
you can even tell if you have an alexa
you can tell them like you know alexa
play the podcast omg high with george
lopez on amazon music
and i got those plans you have those in
the house yeah i do it's great
it's great isn't it yeah but i like but
i like watching the youtube i like
i'm i start laughing and i laugh at
myself
well you know i i listen i i gotta tell
you man i mean
you know brian was just here like maybe
three episodes but when gil
took over it became a you made it a
different podcast
right oh yeah what's different about it
um it's just more
the vibe i mean it's hard to nail down
but like people i i look at the youtube
comments i shouldn't because that's a
terrible place to be but like
every time it's like oh [ __ ] if
you're gone it's like where the [ __ ] is
gil and if you're here it's like oh
yeah gill's back baby no i know but they
yeah and nobody
i mean you talked about a guy that
criticized but i think more people
like this i think i don't know i don't
know oh no doubt more people
like yeah the show but if you if you're
not if you don't have haters
i mean i would hate to be a hater i used
to be a hater but i would hate to be
somebody that spent time wishing other
people harm
oh yeah it was some nba player i want to
say like chris chris bosh or something
like that and he was talking about how
he dealt with a lot of hate coming up
and he just started to treat it as like
math he's like if i'm going to be on
this biggest stage like
there's no way everyone's going to like
me in a group of five people not
everyone's going to like that that's
that's the absolute truth you know and i
i get it because there were a lot of
haters as i was coming up
well as a matter of fact if you look at
the documentary there were haters that
didn't think that
it was one person yeah and they made fun
of you and i think it went easy when
they said they would they would tease
you but
i'm pretty sure the way police tease is
not as simple as you made it sound
well the only one you know the the guys
in my department
uh in my homicide beer there's only a
couple of guys that came and got in my
face
uh and there was the
one agency in particular and i had a
friend on the inside
and he says gil every time you walk out
their mother [ __ ] knew up to one side
and down the other they were sincere
and there was a sergeant i want to say
his name was o'connor the night of
uh july the 7th when sophie dickman got
hit
and the informant which was right lived
right across the street from sophie
dickman
she was a member of the sheriff's
department she did work her crime lab
yes
and she was on the documentary that's
right linda arthur and
i got there and she lived across the
street and i got the message
called her up i thought she got to come
down here sophie dickman just got hit
i think it's related so i go down and
i'm standing across the street
out of their crime scene out of their
way and that sergeant saw me and he came
on over and the first words out of his
mouth were
what the [ __ ] are you doing here wow and
i just said oh
good morning to you too you know and i
never let him see that it bothered me
anything like that
unfortunately uh his captain was there
with him his captain was a little bit
embarrassed said come on in we'll let
you take a look right now
but uh they were you know and they were
led by
the leader of that department i won't
mention his name but he was the leader
he knows who he is
and he just wanted his department to
solve the case
we were big brother to him and the the
smaller department wanted to solve the
case and
what he didn't realize is we didn't care
who saw that as long as it was solved
well i think that's i mean if you if you
listen to be real which i
i would he would say that you don't [ __ ]
with the sheriffs in the lapd
you're like iffy on them like whatever
so if they're trying to solve the crime
to be
uh big in the in
and whatever you just want to solve the
crime they did not have the manpower or
the war
the logistical power to do it
they just didn't when you talk about how
many murders there were how big their
department is
we had people we could staff all over
the county they didn't
you know they could take care of how
about this i'm out in the the manson
case
when they were leaving they changed
clothes
and they were on mulholland and they
threw the clothes over
and it was a reporter from abc that said
okay so
if they left let's get in the car and
let me change clothes in the car
and let me see at what point are we
where they would
throw the clothes out the window and
then they look over
and there's the [ __ ] clothes down the
hill and
that is like your mother-in-law fighting
now finding something that you did wrong
and she found it for you know that you
hate it but it's somebody like that
investigator
just think that that reporter thinking
outside the box
hey let's try what is it going to cost
me other than time
and they found and you know when the
police when the other people showed up
there they go well how did you uh
find find out guys like you know there
was somebody that you know had some
inside information i mean
the reporter just said let me get in the
back let me change clothes
and there they and there it was they
were the clothes a real a real
homicide investigator and he's now dead
a guy named charlie gunther he was one
of my heroes you know he
he's an old guy short sleeves and he
rolled his sleeves up
wore taps on his wingtip shoes you know
always had a piece of tobacco or a
cigarette or a cigar in his mouth
and he didn't care who solved what crime
and he when the night stalker case once
we had an arrest
they had private investigators helping
them out now he's
the investigators on the defense side of
this case
charlie gunther had an unsolved case and
he comes up to one of the investigations
hey
you got some free time i'd like you to
take a look at this just give me a fresh
view
because he didn't have all the answers
and you take help from wherever you can
get it
those cops that think they're too good
you know hey
you're a reporter what do you know well
you know you take any advice you can
last point but but you know in mind
hunter whatever that guy wrote a book
but
they you know they had to convince the
fbi or convince law enforcement
that you could prevent a crime before it
happened
instead of being reactive with the right
information
following traits right i guess am i am i
close
i don't know i've never been able to
yeah you know
prevent prevent something other than an
obvious gang murder you know this
this body at this party and you know who
got hit over here you know
well you know that they're going to
retaliate right so now you focus over
here so when these guys come across the
line you get them before they shoot
okay that you know you know what's going
to happen
but aside from that i don't see yeah
good stop it
all right all right voicemails uh george
pop pop quiz now that you got some of
that uh weed in here what's the voice
mail number
[ __ ] 818 533 1843 i can never
i'm dyslexic i can five three you think
you would have it in here five three
eight one eight oh yeah just call leave
voicemail for for george gail to answer
well you know
what do you want people to ask about we
got all over the board but let's ask
some questions
live we've got some questions for gil
81853 1840. oh i can't remember that all
right here's the first one
away we go oh just leave it right there
i see it right there on the screen
hola jorge big fan
i have a question i am happily married
but about once or twice a year i get
this crazy urge to [ __ ] somebody else
like cheat on my husband
straight up wow what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me am i just a footballer is this
normal she's the best
guy ever i don't know what is wrong what
do you think is wrong is this normal
or am i [ __ ] up thanks you know i
don't know who that is but
i already want to invite her to my house
can we hear it again that that's just
such a listen i
i'm not sure i'm not sure why i've been
neglecting voicemails if they're going
to be like that
um that's a good voicemail that is a
very honest lady
and i love the honesty listen if there's
if there's any place for a latino to be
honest
it is on that what's the number guilt
hey it is with your eyes eight one eight
five three three eight one four three
let's hear it again
18 43 1843 leave that up there
throw it on screen the horp then the
number to the horvap university hotline
you wanna hear it again this is the
harvard university hotline
how can i help you here we go i'm sorry
from the top
plus this boutique one i love her but
this is a great one
grand come on [ __ ] [ __ ]
big fan i have a question i
am happily married but
about once or twice a year i get this
crazy urge to [ __ ] somebody
[Laughter]
what do you think is wrong is this
normal or am i [ __ ] up
thanks
did she answer her own question
uh no but what do you think george
what's uh what are the thoughts on the
matter
i'm not george don't look at me
you don't have to speak from experience
this can be a purely academic exercise
i think she's a very nice lady myself
just trying to help society and her own
personal problems out i mean what
i mean you know there's some people that
bring other things into the relationship
i mean you know maybe maybe you know
what maybe her husband
has the same idea that every once in a
while he wouldn't mind banging somebody
else hey she's happily married if this
is going to keep her happily married
i god bless her i don't know how you
would present it to your husband but i'm
not
sure listen i was married for 17 years
they might trick you vance said what if
we brought somebody else into the
bedroom and i said yeah that'd be great
then you're
like [ __ ] that's a trick
question i i got nothing to say because
i'll tell you right now
if my wife listens to this and listens
to me laughing
she's not gonna be happy we're gonna cut
you out of this part right here but but
i i think that you would almost
um man grant i don't know what you would
do you
talk to your husband about it and say
listen maybe a marital aid a toy
something's just a whole lot of leave a
lot
exactly exactly no but i mean i think
her question ultimately was like you
know
am i [ __ ] up and i think the answer is
pretty much like no no
that's a pretty natural thing sure like
sure forever's a long time
monogamy is is a you know it's an
agreement it's it's not
really the way we're watching monogamy's
good i always like park place
[Laughter]
i like the boardwalk so so yes i think
that's a good point
is that it's a contract it's not
it's not necessarily how we're built
either like it's not how people are
built
you know so i'm a modern guy it's like
you can get away with whatever
everyone agrees with i think so don't
don't think that that you're [ __ ] up
because you're not
that's right to that wonderful lady that
called no you eat the same ice cream
every day you get tired of the same ice
cream even if it's inspiring
yeah so i would say i would say
ultimately no
that it's almost healthy to have that
identity
i'm not sure if you have a partner like
let's see that you know that what her
husband thinks but
there's people i think that step out you
know swingers
or or maybe they say just don't
embarrass me you used to hear that
yeah well i think i think it was my
therapist who told me too it's like it's
not the
it's not the first thought that matters
right like it's it's what you do with it
right if a part of you is like
suddenly like [ __ ] i want to cheat you
like wait a second i'm not going to do
that
i love this person that's what matters
anybody out there with the same thought
call eight one eight five three three
one eight four three i don't know but
okay but can we agree that she's not
[ __ ] up
no but yeah fully agree i think it's
healthy but then to
to a latina or to a latino you think
that
a healthy thought is [ __ ] up i love my
husband
a couple times a year i want i get the
urge to [ __ ] somebody else
what's wrong with me nothing absolutely
nothing you're not
a puta you're not a put up but you may
be a pit
in training
[Laughter]
all right next moving right along
more hard questions here we go hi george
this is jane and i just have a quick
question for both you
and gil what's your take on jeffrey
epstein's death do you think it was
truly a suicide great question
that is a great question you know on it
on its face with the things went on uh
in the beginning and we only know what
you and everybody else in the public
knows
but it's certainly extremely suspicious
to
an old investigator's eyes you know
about it being a suicide they're
not enough information pushed out i
don't know what they're holding back but
i would say
no uh cellmate removed cameras uh
being worked on an operative sir
something like the guys who were
watching him were on their like
fourth consecutive shift or something
like that so basically asleep or
something yeah
so i i don't think uh
i would say no i don't think
i'm subject to being wrong also on
in in russia vladimir putin alleged
someone was taken out on a bridge uh
they jumped over the bridge
and the cameras were being repaired that
weekend and there was no footage of the
guy
you know had enough of his life and
jumped over the bridge
and um you know i think jeffrey epstein
alleged the first time it didn't work
and then the second time
but clearly let's see with the female
uh maxwell that's in custody yes
if anything happens to her or i mean
listen
uh they know a lot of names
let's see if she calls in to ask if
she's a puta yeah
hi george i used to be with jeffrey
epstein we would take that call
that would be uh maxwell
is that how you say that name la maxwell
maxwell she's a graduate of harvard
university of sherman oaks california
established 1978. i mean she's got jizz
in her name come on
we got to do the horvath university
t-shirt too that feels like good merch
the horvath
uh gail i don't know why you're not
puffing on one of these because i've
already
taken three pups i'm already trying to
figure out what i'm going to do tomorrow
[Laughter]
okay one more five more uh we got we got
time here we got couple more um
all right next up oh volume helps
i think i'm sucking out okay even got a
cradle
anybody want a beef jerky be while we're
waiting
[Laughter]
what up george this is ben from north
carolina just saying
there was a stand-up comedian named tim
wilson that a lot of road comedians in
the south really enjoyed but he passed
away in like 2014 and doesn't really get
any recognition are there any uh
stand-up comedians you met on your way
up or like
in the 90s 2000s there that nobody knows
about but all the comedians loved or
like you love specifically
just that oh man that's something oh
that's a great question you know what i
think i knew
tim wilson yeah i saw you nodding during
the uh the voicemail there
um i think i you know what i if it's who
i think it is
i
one thing that comes to mind did you
have any experience with freddy soto i
feel like he was a lot of people sort of
uh freddie soto yeah i did not know tim
wilson but
uh yeah you know a lot of those guys
rodney carrington
still living but was uh incredibly
successful
in a genre like in the south and then
when my show was on abc he had a deal to
do
a show at abc and it didn't work out um
so
you know he's incredibly successful but
it's it's hard to take you know somebody
that
is there's no guarantee that if you're
successful
that'll translate to tv you know jeff
foxworthy
was had an incredible has had an
incredible career
and had a show on nbc and it didn't work
uh tim wilson i did not know but freddy
soto
uh had a show i mean freddy soto was on
the way up
he was out there when i was when i was
doing it and i think that freddy soto
would have been somebody that
people would have heard of you know
incredibly charismatic
um charming dude good dude
i can keep oh deed i think he yeah it
was
something tragic and it was something
i'm really surprised uh
angela johnson right good entertainer
good good-looking young ladies very
articulate very sharp
former radaret i'm really surprised that
you know for whatever the reason because
i don't know the business at all but i
would think that she would have
transitioned into something more than
stand up just what she's doing you know
i think i would agree i mean angela
johnson's
has always been incredibly
charismatic wonderful personality comes
across
on stage uh attractive
did her work has done her time and um
you know there's there's
well i mean it's hard to say but i would
think that
if you look at uh tim allen when tim
allen before had a show he got involved
with
matt uh williams who created the show um
drew carey was a was successful in his
show
and he was with bruce helford i you know
would say hey where's my bruce alfred
bruce alford and i did my first show
and i think maybe you know having a show
runner
that is of that caliber makes a huge
difference
and i think that when comedians are
coming up if you don't
have a showrunner of a particular
caliber it's like going into a gunfight
with
a knife you want you don't want to show
up with a knife but also
you think that if you hold out maybe you
don't find somebody better maybe there's
not a better deal
but i can't speak for angela but i would
i would be surprised
what her story would be if we brought
her in here and we asked
why aren't you you know haven't had
either a movie career
or a tv career not that she hasn't had a
great career but
if you i think you would ask her every
comedian aspires to be
a star of their own show and a very
personable lady invited backstage got to
meet her
just a wonderful uh wonderful leader and
great entertainer yeah
and at the end she's got that latina
accent if she wants to go the latinos
i think that that's i think that that's
part of it like you know and that you
know
nail salon poncho oh god that is
hilarious
i mean sometimes that's sometimes that's
enough
to to get through yeah but that's a
great question good question
that was a good question yes cool uh do
you want to wrap it up no let's do it
let me do more one more for guillen all
right
this is a good show again it is i i
thought that question
this uh gil this one's for you
these bastards are playing one second
am i gonna go golf yeah what time is it
oh yeah
3 50 you think i would have [ __ ]
brought my sticks over here
my bottle was like you guys hearing
anything and so i'm not hearing anything
either no that one
is a [ __ ] look all right i can ask
that question which was simply
sophia vergara or selma hayek that was
the entirety of the voicemail
i don't care either way either one of
them or
perla but she's calling no
um some hayek
you know i was on my show i had a thing
for someone i put it in the show
did you yeah i put it in the show that
if i had my show i'd put it
i met her uh you know you know what's
funny matt is
is you know when you start to when you
start to have a little bit of success
you you don't
you know i remember she told me we were
going to do a movie we were we were
talking about doing
the remake of war of the roses with with
uh
michael douglas we were married to each
other and
we talked you know i talked to her about
it i went to her office
and i remember she said to me because my
show got cancelled and i was you know
and the press not happy and i remember
she said to me what the [ __ ]
are you so [ __ ] miserable about you
want to
spend your [ __ ] life in a [ __ ]
stage you don't see the [ __ ] light
you don't see your [ __ ] life
you want to be trapped in a [ __ ]
stage i was like oh
all right that makes sense you want you
want to be put away for another three
years when you could be doing other [ __ ]
and then the george clooney's office was
right across from
the stage at warner brothers because
ellen was er
then it became alan then george
clooney's office of mine and one day we
were on a break and
we saw some a couple people walking in
the guard said that's
some hayak right there and i said selma
turned around
saw me and started running towards me i
was eating popcorn we had a popcorn
thing was eating popcorn and i looked at
the guard and the people and i go soma
hayek is running toward me
and she comes up and she she grabs some
popcorn out of thing puts it on
eats it and then we talk a little bit
gives me a kiss and you can taste the
salt from the popcorn on the so that's
what i
that's what i do right before i light a
fire right
it's been a fantastic show gail i love
you man thank you and thank you again
grant aaron
you you never see i'll throw over there
[ __ ] uh
bosley of charlie's angel exactly uh
thank you man a lot of fun bro thank you
awesome thanks guys
you